freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
heutigen video wir sind heute zu gast
bei max lorenz bei unseren ehren bruder
und er hat mich hier in seine heiligen
hain in sein restaurant empfang ich
werde nämlich heute käse und wein
kennenlernen und das in der ganzen
bandbreite also wir werden sowohl
preiswerten käse mittelpreisigen krise
aber vor allem teuren wein trinken und
ob sich das lohnt ob ich als laie
überhaupt verstehe was das ganze
bedeutet das sehen wir jetzt also da
sind wir jetzt den max kennt ja
mittlerweile es kommt bald noch etwas
auf euch zu sagen immer gesagt ich muss
hier mal ein praktikum machen meine
sterne gas praktikum und mit ihren wenig
stars des heutigen videos diese und
weinbar gewünscht ja das heißt wir
führen ich heute musst du so leicht auf
die schlachtbank das duschen die
wirklichkeiten rein kommst du wirklich
dann bald markieren lassen lässt man
aber erstmal dem entspannten teil oder
wir haben fünf verschiedene käse fünf
verschiedene weine und wie gesagt das
ganze steigert sich ein bisschen beim
käse muss man sagen dass bleibt in einem
relativ dezenten rahmen das ist übrigens
das ist auch wieder unterstützt
funktionär also vom französischen käse
verband deshalb denke ich wird das
wieder ganz schön lecker sein beim käse
haben wir natürlich ein deutlich
schmaleren rahmen hazel kann sich
eigentlich jeder leisten bei wein ist es
so es wird schnell sehr luxuriöse du
kannst davon viel erzählen du hast ja
eigentlich auch einen fokus ein stück
weit schon noch weise jetzt wo wir drin
sitzen den heiligen hallen im eindruck
gerade uns zusammen und haben wir
insgesamt 1004 positionen und kannst wir
uns sage ich mal einen leckeren riesling
für 22 24 uhr trinken aber du kannst
halt auch ein kleinwagen pro flasche
ausgehen heißt warum viele geldspenden
bedacht das heißt flaschen des oktobers
18 20
1080 euro für eine flasche wein der max
auch jetzt ist die teuerste jemals
verkaufte flasche waren 600.000 euro
gerne ist auf jeden fall der sache wo
ich mich auch sehr viel spaß also ich
bin gespannt wo fangen wir unsere ersten
an wir haben als erstes eine ganz
einfache und französischen hartkäse 100
prozent und dazu vielleicht etwas
unüblich kann mit einem kreis war einmal
ganz gleich
ob in deutschland weil ich würde ein
profi erst den wein und dann den käse
käse wird immerhin will cool irrt man
auch weiß was glaubst du kannst also ein
klassisch geht es darum dabei
verschlossen dass der luft bekommen es
gibt so kannst du natürlich so ganz
schön anstrengen kann
ist schon ist schon ein bisschen
speziell hat schon ein bisschen mehr
ecke und kann ja ja merckx den alkohol
die nur elementar brauchst um gegen käse
zu setzen ich habe dir einfach mal stück
starken bericht noch gar nicht so stark
kann man sagen dass käseteller ist desto
mehr riecht er also weil länger gereift
ist und sonst ich habe nachher was krise
2008 sind die nächsten die eingebaut
werden muss handwerklich gut gemacht
sein dass wir das wurde in frankreich
gibt darauf diese premier käse die auf
dem bauernhof hergestellt wird und wohin
genau das der fall der ist echt lecker
also ich finde das ist so ein käse wäre
würde jeder mögen das ist so kilger
einstieg da wurde längst ach komm abends
ging dem wirklich auswahl auf dem brot
essen haben wir total soso geiles
schwarzbrot schön französischen
süßenguth darunter ja das macht lust auf
mehr und das ist ja schon mal eine gute
grundstein weil bisher konnte ich mit
beidem nicht wahnsinnig viel anfangen
spannendste frage was kostet käse was
kostet das für mich muss raten wir ihn
niemand von kilopreis ich würde sagen
der kostet dann 20 euro kilo nicht ganz
billigen über 15 krass würde ich würde
ich jederzeit bezahlen geld meist käse
war ich gar nicht so scharf aber beim
wein sagt sie ehrlich wir sind dir in
deinen laden ihr hier gibt es
prinzipiell scheinbar sagt wir können
heute auch ein kleinwagen zu saufen ja
wir sind wir sind ja am einstieg 15 euro
sie hätte ich das 21
also finde ich auch zum schönen essen zu
einem guten käse auch absolut kein ja
nächsten krise kennen wir schon falls
ihr euch erinnert die ganze
aufmerksamkeit aus unserem archiv video
aber ich habe ihn gar nicht roh gegessen
deshalb bin ich auch sehr gespannt auf
die nächste krise in der unbedingt ja
ein memo let me roll at der immer gleich
ganz so genannte farbe liegt an blüten
der wird mit blüten gefärbten relativ
neutral riecht sehr sehr lecker sehr
dezent auch für käse und verspannt
wachsen gerade dazu auf macht eben
gerade man ja ja ich mache jetzt ein
bisschen deutsche lande deutschland
deutschland der bau eines komplett
unfiltriert nur durch halt schicht
matten nicht irgendwie mit hefe gekehrt
und ist sozusagen immer so ein bisschen
das potpourri des winzers was da drin
ist also ein cuvée ist noch nicht
unterschrieben hat insgesamt 67 sollten
und ich werde einfach mal sagen
probieren weil ich schalte den käse und
du meinst du erinnerst weinkeller
gelernt hast ich finde wirklich das ist
so geil auf einem kanal wir haben
angefangen vor einem jahr mit bis hin
kochen und irgendwie überleben jetzt
waren wir schon in guten restaurants sie
lernen wollen kämpfen und diese reise so
zu dokumentieren ist gerade wieder so
ein moment zwischen denker wie geil ist
das eigentlich
die ich habe dann gleich nochmal so
dieses bisschen spülen nenne ich jetzt
meinen also was man da alles schmeckt
plötzlich jetzt noch mal die käse dazu
amoled wie sieht das auf jeden fall
schon mal so schön gepasst
ich verstehe warum das warum das den
dingen ist nur käse und bei der löst so
diese ganze säure alles was von beidem
und ist löst ja so ein bisschen aus also
es ist krass ihr bein hat hat einen
schönen körper das heißt du hast noch zu
viel alkohol also das habe ich gerade
bildschirm das war für mich schon der
erste kranke aha moment du hast das
beschrieben ich habe das getränk da ist
so viel schon was so im mund passiert
dass ich jetzt schon sagen würde der
wein kostet lockern vw locker was kosten
der krise bei dem käse findig gerät das
ja so wenn du merkst richtung der es
fertig so der funktioniert gut zu diesem
wein weil der wein macht soviel und der
käse hat die cremigkeit dies unterstützt
ich sage der krise liegt bei 30 euro pro
kilo
27 bis 30 also ganz genau weil bis jetzt
nicht nehmen league sehr gut dran der
beiden was hast du ihm geschätzt 50 zoll
an also auf den einen euro weil man es
jetzt nicht mehr automatisch fest liegen
aber ja machen wir leer und auch zur
nächsten station ist natürlich zu krass
dieser tag hörte was haben wir hier kam
ihr dann euren die also quasi weichkäse
mit einem deutschen wein und ein dessert
süß war aber jetzt lassen wir den ball
mal beiseite stellen ob wir uns am käse
zeitung habe ich denen dazu ausgesucht
er hat wahrscheinlich jeder wirklich
jeder schon mal also kam der ist so
trick creme kann deshalb wahrscheinlich
mit etwas süßem gut zusammengehen naja
ich habe mir noch mehr süße wird
gerechnet nachdem das gesagt hast bei
dem geruch zumindest
boa hat sich frisch er alkohol hast du
natürlich aber bemerkt diese power diese
kraft nicht so dieses so ja das ist das
ist rot war mit zucker versteckt und
jetzt kommt das interessanter zu dem
käse den wir hier anschauen was ich sehr
extrem mit cremigkeit vorher total liegt
es dann fällt mir jetzt
genau ist das merkmal kann mir ist ja
einfach zu schafft so wird sie an
discounter kam er ist halt einfach nur
weiß und kennt der hat halt schon denn
schon ecken und kanten der aktion reifen
merkt schon dass das dass der anfängen
bis hin zu werden und jetzt dagegen dann
quasi diesen deutschen
wirklich wahnsinnig gut schmecke ich
habe noch gar nichts dazu gesagt
wer kommt es so krass aber das ist
wirklich heftig sind es genau dadurch
dass wir diesen ablauf gewittern er wird
wein käse schluck wein käse bereitet den
weg für den wein das schmeckt so viel
verständlicher prägnanter du hast wenn
du diesen gegenpol cremiges hass und
danach dem schlug vor die süßen wein
trinkt ist dass der schmeckt doppelt so
süß jetzt macht das sinn das absolut
recht der kam er ist kein massen
discounter ding gerade bei diesen
französischen familie käsen die so einem
kleinen patches produziert werden
schmeckt man das auch trotzdem als laie
würde ich sagen kann wer kann nicht zu
teuer werden und ich würde somit 35 euro
im kino geht und ich auf 40 für dich
okay aber immer noch preislich absolute
wir reden hilft und alles was wird das
250 gramm hinzu kommen also reden wir
von zehn dafür sind genug ja das heißt
so ein stückchen kostet nach irgendwas
was wir gerade gegessen haben 80 90 cent
absolut habt ihr das tut immer noch am
ersten stück bist ja und ich so damit
beschäftigen kannst ja gut zu dir sagen
ich mal beim discounter euro für eine
packung fleisch wurst und schmeißt du
nicht rein und hier kannst dich wirklich
mit mit deinem lebensmitteln das ist ein
ganz ganz wichtiger punkt der world wind
so wir auf diesem kanal haben wir
einfach auch spaß am essen sowie rim
sprachen kennen zu lernen zu verstehen
sich da auszuprobieren du noch 1000 mal
mehr als sternekoch daraus kannst du so
viel freude ziehen und es muss ja nicht
diese der käse ist ja für jeden bezahlen
auch den teuersten käse kann es ja jeder
leisten und wie viel spaß man damit
haben kann also das ding ist was hier
trügerisch ist ich weiß natürlich
gegangen steigerungen bringst jetzt auch
nicht die ganze flasche und trinken ein
glas und verschließen genau klar 85 euro
noch höher 90 wir werden daher ständig
100 100 das macht wirklich spaß also das
ist eine richtig gute abend
beschäftigung dritter gang ist es
wirklich entgangen weil jeder einzelne
schritt wieder 10 cent macht sinn und
etwas ganz neues und deshalb freue ich
mich auch nummer vier wir haben hier den
kommt der reserve das ist jedes jahr
immer wieder der meist prämierte kommt
also wir merken es geht bergauf mich nur
beim wein sondern auch beim käse kommt
kennt wahrscheinlich jeder von euch und
es gibt von diesem kommt jährlich 80.000
räder wir fangen wieder an mit über eine
ganz kurze erzählt er wir sind beim
weingut gaia der fünf besten weingüter
italiens bei einem seiner seiner seiner
großen lage sind so einem schönen
reichen jahr 2007 wir sind in der
toskana und mehr möchte ich gar nicht
sagen ausser ein wort in gioia
unerwartet ist noch nicht auf der hat
sich gerade heute wirst du jetzt schon
gespannt offen gewesen oha das gericht
jetzt gerade und das ist kein scheiß 10
war so intensiv wie nach dem aus der
flasche kommt
so was sagst du zum käse ich habe die
ganze angst auch bei den verschiedenen
käsen irgendwie was kommt was mich so um
haut bei alles davon schmeckt richtig
richtig gut dass er immer mit richtig
deutsch wenn man so irgendwie käse reift
über seien nur ein paar sagt in der
sonne keine ecke ist aber dass erinnert
sich ganz klar vom geschmack daran aber
der ist halt wesentlich kemming der ist
wesentlich wohltuend paris an den den
rubels darüber dass trocken genauso in
paestum macht sind auf einer pasta macht
sind von mir ist auch noch auf gewisse
fleischgerichte aber das ist immer ein
addon hier ganz klar der käse im
vordergrund hier wirst du vielleicht
einen kurz gebratenes stück brot
geflügel machen und das da drauf gehen
dann wird es einfach nur ein bisschen
tomaten aufsteigen den käse drauf legt
der käse ist hier ganz klar dass da im
anderen es der parmesan das addon jetzt
der weit das riecht so elegant der
portwein gerade war sie so lecker ich
finde schon ob da noch was für mich
rankommen
beine ist ein scheiß teures hobby
es schmeckt auch teuer es wird richtig
teuer weiß ja es wird teurer der letzten
runde gekostet und ich weiß dieses ding
hier ist wahrscheinlich eine sache die
man sich normalerweise einmal im jahr
weil heute beispielsweise zwei jahre zum
valentinstag an die wichtigste frage ist
schmeckt ihr dabei ich sage ganz ehrlich
er schmeckt sehr gut aber ich würde
immer mit dem porträt ist natürlich eine
ganz andere familie sohn also aber als
anfänger ist mir das wahrscheinlich ich
weiß nicht wie viel es kostet das geld
noch nicht wert dafür musst du wein
besser verstehen wenn jetzt wieder und
sein lieblingsspiel was kostet käse was
passt ja mal ich schätze wenn ich dafür
250 euro kostet nach 280 380 euro lesung
was sagst du dazu preisliche käse 50
euro im kilo gemanagt genau richtig wir
haben hier wie viel liegen das sind
vielleicht 150 gramm 200 gramm käse
ultrakleinen sehr lecker aber ich würde
ihn so wahrscheinlich nicht also ich
wäre nicht zufrieden wäre mich nicht
happy nichtsdestotrotz ist das so ein
erlebnis macht so viel spaß ich muss
auch mal ruhig dankeschön sagen dass wir
hier zu gast sein dürfen ja ich habe
richtig respekt davor was jetzt kommt
ich muss kurz innehalten weil wir sicher
was jetzt kommt werde ich lange lange
lange lange nicht mehr erleben diese
dieses grinsen nicht weil du dich über
mein erlebnis vor sagen weil du selbst
einfach noch mal bock drauf habe es
wahrscheinlich ja
was hat ihnen gesagt dass du beim
rotwein sagst du bist raus ja ich will
ja
das ziel ist ja heute quasi von günstig
bis teuer zu trinken ja
rauschtrinken wir einfach mal
wir wechseln im klaren gerade hier
wächst in den plattenbauten es bringt
nichts so eine tolle aufzureißen wo der
winzer wirklich alles rein jetzt sein
herz gehört und jetzt nichts gegen dich
du sagst du verstehst es nicht hier aber
da wir beim letzten käse wieder bei dem
weichkäse sind könnte das mit einem sehr
sehr schönen gereiften champagner gegen
klötze irgendwas passt besser dazu als
100 punkte champagner ich weiß überhaupt
nicht was du gerade sagt so was ich
gerade gesagt eine 100 100 paar kaputte
robert parker hat damals weine oder
bewertet heute immer noch so sehr sehr
angesehen und das ding ist hat quasi
sieht auch dass von 100 100 von 100 mehr
geht nicht auf die art das sieht auch so
aus altach ist natürlich darf nicht
altern anwesenheit von so einem teuren
champagner sein
okay wir haben eine chance für das ist
der ganze käse das ist der ganze leib
und es unterscheidet sich bei den
anderen käsen die 20 30 40 kilo schwer
sind das ist das exclusive sind was wir
auf der liste haben ist es trotzdem
bezahlbar was du hier gerade auf machst
es ist das muss man einfach auch mal
festhalten für viele leute nicht und das
ist auch vollkommen okay da gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch vergleichbares aber
das ist königsklasse es gebe im löwen
rhein-ruhr jo jo jo
ok
das sieht außergewöhnlich austrag ist
schnell zu
stellen wir uns
aussagen organs bis sich alles gemeinsam
geschmeckt hat
er sie geht richtig ab jetzt
macht das fertig sind diese kombination
die der käse der ist ja fast flüssig
diese cremigkeit dieses dieses nussige
dieses hätte wirklich auch nicht gedacht
dass ich einen käfer mit seiner
konsistenz so lecker finden könnte und
jetzt kommt hier nehmen auch mal den
champagner in dem man brot wird den
großen schluck zu ihrem und reife birnen
reife quitte ganz bisschen floralen
noten sowie einen blumenstrauß vom
eingegangen und dann kommt dieses
theoretische karamell dieses holz dieses
so ein bisschen ein bisschen dreckigen
und dann ist ja
perfekt
das zu viel das ist so krass das ist so
lecker was kostet denn der kostet so
viel geld und erstmal wieder für jeden
erschwinglich wahrscheinlich lag es ja
nicht sagen weil es nichts
langweiligeres der spaß macht hier ist
der kilopreis auch ein bisschen unfair
weil christian jetzt in der welt schale
der ist das individuelle stück ist viel
mehr viel mehr arbeit als bei so einem
großen deshalb sage ich der kostet 75
euro 80 8 mio und das heißt mit anderen
worten hier haben wir keine 120 130 aber
es hilft ihr ein 10 18 euro vielleicht
sofort das ist so krass das ist als
würdest du die cremige leckerste käse
pasta essen aber du hast nur die hilfe
der jüngsten käse passt aber so lecker
und der champagner der kostet das hab
ich jetzt so wie es ist 5 600
das ist schon wieder jetzt so ein ding
ich sitzen davor die flasche aus 600
euro ich habe das gerade gedruckt ich
habe davon keinen plan das ist so krass
sind 600 euro das ist kunst das ist
wirklich kunst ist das trifft es gut das
ist kunst das sind das sind
handverlesene flaschen der von abt ja ja
also große große große erkenntnis aus
diesem video guter käse
acht guten weinen noch viel besser und
guter wein hebt guten käse
wahrscheinlich auf die stufe endgegner
hey das ist so heftig ich möchte ich
noch mal beim 10 ihre gedanken so ein
video möglich zu machen und mir dieses
erlebnis möglich zu machen genau
gleichermaßen ziemlich dafür bei dir
bedanken max so krass so cool einfach
eine neue welt eröffnet der ausschluss
ich mit meiner 600 euro sparen wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder ich nicht
damit jetzt erstmal los aber bislang
nicht haben dankeschön